hurricane Harvey has caused significant
damage along a big part of the Texas
coast the storm is heading Northwest
winds have decreased to about a hundred
miles per hour
DeMarco Morgan is in Galveston this
morning DeMarco good morning good
morning Dana to you well the wind is
still coming out of full speed the rain
has been off and on but we've talked
about 40 mile-per-hour winds and topped
at least 50 mile-per-hour winds and I
know Maine well I talked about it being
90 miles per hour but imagine this this
is just some of the debris that has
fallen off of one of the buildings this
coming at you even with 50 mile-per-hour
winds behind it it's still extremely
dangerous remember it's not always the
wind it that kills you it's what's in
the wind so you want to be extremely
careful we've seen people coming out
here taking selfies so be very careful
if you're coming outside just to take in
these winds we got palm trees out here
that have been blowing that's just the
familiar sign the also familiar sign
whenever a hurricane or tropical storm
is in the area but this is something
that is extremely dangerous because
Harvey is expected to soak Galveston and
the Houston area for the next several
days Galveston's record for total
rainfall over a five-day span is 16
inches set back in 1900 over the next
five days again the city could get more
than 20 inches of rain and there was a
flash flood watch through Tuesday
evening which could cause widespread
damage to homes and businesses streets
will likely be flooded for several days
and on the boulevard Peninsula just
north of here three homes were destroyed
by a wind fueled fire it's not
immediately clear if they were occupied
and if all of this isn't enough there is
also a threat of tornadoes northeast of
Galveston and it could also put us in
that area where we could be facing those
tornado threats and again we've spotted
some people out here that's why you want
to be extremely careful if you're coming
out here we've spotted people a group of
five on a bike on several bikes about an
hour ago at this time in the morning
with these winds just going around and
doing site scene folks be careful if you
don't have to come outside please don't
do it stay inside we'll send things back
to you
all right DeMarco thank you be safe
DeMarco Morgan in Galveston Texas this
morning